PRIVATELY EXPRESSING CONCERNS
ABOUT THOSE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THE FORMER PRESIDENT TOOK.
>> ARLETTE SAENZ, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME NOW IS PETER STRUCK,
AN FBI INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL WHO
PLAYED A CENTRAL ROLE IN THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL AND TRUMP
RUSSIA INVESTIGATIONS.
HE'S ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BOOK, COMPROMISED:
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AND THE
THREAT OF DONALD J. TRUMP.
PETER, YOU'RE PERFECT TO TALK TO
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
SITUATION, AND IT'S INTERESTING
THAT WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS ARE
PRIVATELY EXPRESSING THESE
CONCERNS, THAT THIS MATERIAL AT
MAR-A-LAGO COULD POTENTIALLY
JEOPARDIZE U.S. SOURCES AND
METHODS FOR INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING.
I SUPPOSE THEY'RE NOT TIPPING
THEIR HAND THAT THEY THINK THE
DOCUMENTS THEMSELVES ARE
SENSITIVE.
BUT THERE IS A CONCERN, I
SUPPOSE.
HOW DANGEROUS WOULD IT BE TO
HAVE DOCUMENTS LIKE THIS LAYING
AROUND THE BASEMENT OF
MAR-A-LAGO IN A STOREROOM THAT
ORIGINALLY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A
PADLOCK ON IT, APPARENTLY.
>> WELL, JIM, IT'S A HUGE DEAL.
LOOK, THIS IS THE REAL STORY.
IT IS NOT A QUESTION OF TRUMP'S
MAJOR FILING THAT HE'S ALLEGING
OR RELEASING VIDEO OF THE
SEARCH.
THE BIG ISSUE AT THE END OF THE
DAY IS THE NIGHTMARE SCENARIO
THAT YOU HAVE EXTRAORDINARILY
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, DOCUMENTS
THAT MIGHT IMPACT THE LIVES OF
AGENTS OVERSEAS, DOCUMENTS THAT
MIGHT IMPACT VERY EXPENSIVE,
VERY SOPHISTICATED INTELLIGENCE
COLLECTION WHETHER ON SATELLITES
OR OTHER SORT OF CYBER MEANS OF
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING.
ALL IN THE POSSESSION OF DONALD
TRUMP WHO HAD NO AUTHORITY TO
HAVE IT, WHO HAD, AS YOU SAID,
STUCK IN A BASEMENT WHERE
NOBODY, HIS ATTORNEYS ON
TELEVISION CAN'T TELL WHETHER 2,
10, 40 PEOPLE HAD ACCESS TO THE
ROOM AND IT PRESENTS FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
COMPLETELY SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
FROM ANY CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
THAT'S GOING ON, IT PRESENTS A
REAL CHALLENGE AND REAL THREAT
TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT ANY OF
THESE INTELLIGENCE SOURCES AND
METHODS ARE AT RISK AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IN TERMS OF ITS
IMPACT ON THE NATIONAL SECURITY
OF THE UNITED STATES.
NOT LAST TERM, NOT LAST YEAR,
BUT RIGHT NOW GOING INTO THE
FUTURE.
>> AND DESPITE ALL OF THAT, WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM SOME
PROMINENT REPUBLICANS THAT THERE
IS SOME KIND OF POLITICAL
CONSPIRACY WHEN THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF THAT.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THE RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE REPUBLICAN MIKE
TURNER.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT'S THE LEADERSHIP.
IT'S THE TWO INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY THIS
PRESIDENT, THE FBI DIRECTOR WRAY
WHO SERVE AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK THAT HAVE QUESTIONS TO
ANSWER TO REPUBLICANS AND
CONGRESS AND TO THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, AND CONDEMN ANY AND
ALL VIOLENCE.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING WHEN PEOPLE
MAKE STATEMENTS LIKE THIS AND IT
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE CONDEMNED.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, JUST A NOTE
THAT CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THE FBI
DIRECTOR WAS APPOINTED BY DONALD
TRUMP, BUT I TAKE YOUR POINT.
>> HE SERVES AT THE PLEASURE OF
THIS PRESIDENT, SO HE IS AN
APPOINTEE OF THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE STAYED.
>> LET ME JUST GET YOUR REACTION
TO THAT, PETER.
>> WELL, I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
IS THERE NO THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY SO LARGE THAT SOME
MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WOULD NOT PLACE THAT ABOVE THEIR
FEALTY TO DONALD TRUMP?
I MEAN, WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SMALL THINGS OR THE LOVE LETTERS
FROM KIM JONG-UN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TOP SECRET
INFORMATION AT THE SENSITIVE
COMPARTMENTED INFORMATION LEVEL,
THINGS THAT ARE SO RESTRICTED,
SO SENSITIVE THAT THEIR RELEASE
WOULD CAUSE EXCEPTIONALLY GRAVE
DAMAGE TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
I DON'T CARE AND I WOULD HOPE A
RESPONSIBLE MEMBER OF CONGRESS
IT WOULDN'T MATTER THE POLITICAL
PARTY OF THE PERSON WHO HAD IT.
IF THEY HAD THIS INFORMATION, IF
THEY WERE PLACING IT AT RISK,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
RISE ABOVE ANY SORT OF PARTISAN
CONCERNS, BUT WE SAW A PATTERN
OVER FOUR YEARS OF TRUMP
ATTACKING THIS NOTION OF SORT OF
PERVERTING THE -- YOU KNOW, I
GREW UP A REPUBLICAN AND IT WAS
THE PARTY OF NATIONAL SECURITY
AND LAW AND ORDER, AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS A CORE
COMPONENT OF THE PARTY.
AND NOW THAT'S ALL GONE.
IT'S SUPPORT IN DEFENSE OF
TRUMP, NATIONAL SECURITY, THE
UNITED STATES BE DAMNED, IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE DOES
BECAUSE HE HAS TO BE PROTECTED
AT ALL COSTS, AND IT'S SHAMEFUL
AND PEOPLE SHOULDN'T BE DOING
IT.
>> PETER WHAT ABOUT THIS NOTION,
I WANTED TO FOLLOW UP WITH THIS,
WHAT IS THE CULTURE LIKE INSIDE
THE FBI?
BECAUSE I GUESS THE GENERAL
NOTION THAT I THINK MOST PEOPLE
HAVE IS THAT IT'S A FAIRLY
CONSERVATIVE INSTITUTION.
I MEAN, IS IT AN INSTITUTION
THAT CONSERVATIVES SHOULD
NATURALLY TRUST MORE THAN OTHER
INSTITUTIONS HERE IN WASHINGTON?
>> ABSOLUTELY IT IS.
I MEAN, LOOK, MY EXPERIENCE
OVER, YOU KNOW, MORE THAN 20
YEARS WAS THAT THE WORK FORCE IS
VERY LARGELY CONSERVATIVE.
IT IS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATION, SO THE IDEAS OF,
YOU KNOW, BEING -- SUPPORTING
LAW ENFORCEMENT, SUPPORTING THE
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE UNITED
STATES ARE VERY STRONG WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THEIR POLITICS, BUT THERE IS A
GENERAL SENSE THAT IT IS A VERY
CONSERVATIVE WORKPLACE, AND
THAT'S WHAT JUST BOGGLES MY
MIND, OVER THE PAST FOUR OR FIVE
YEARS HOW THE ENTIRE REPUBLICAN
PARTY SEEMS TO HAVE TIPPED ON
ITS HEAD SOMETHING THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED FOR
GENERATIONS PRIOR TO THAT, AND
AGAIN, THE ONE REASON THAT I CAN
PUT MY FINGER ON, THE ONE REASON
THAT THEY'VE ABANDONED THIS SORT
OF SUPPORT FOR THE NATIONAL
SECURITY OF THE UNITED STATES IS
FALLING UNDER THE THRALL OF
DONALD TRUMP, AND ANYTHING THAT
WOULD POSE POTENTIALLY A THREAT
TO HIM OR A CHALLENGE TO HIM
NECESSARILY BECOMES THE ENEMY.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
DRIVING THIS SORT OF
CONDEMNATION AND CRITICISM OF
THE FBI RIGHT NOW.
>> AND I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS, OUR REPORTING IS THAT
TRUMP IS CONSIDERING WHETHER TO
RELEASE THE ACTUAL SURVEILLANCE
FOOTAGE OF THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH
TO FIRE UP HIS SUPPORTERS.
HE'S ALREADY PULLED IN
BILLIONS -- OR MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF FUND-RAISING OFF OF
THIS SEARCH.
I MEAN, HOW DOES THAT -- HOW
DOES THAT STRIKE YOU THAT HE
WOULD POTENTIALLY RELEASE THIS
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE.
TO ME IT SOUNDS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS TRUMP THROWING SOME
CATNIP OUT THERE HOPING TO, YOU
KNOW, GENERATE ONE MORE NEWS
CYCLE OF COVERAGE ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HE FIRES UP HIS
BASE WITH.
>> YEAH, WELL, I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY A LOT WORSE THAN CATNIP
IN THIS CASE.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT, HE'S GOING TO
USE IT TO GATHER MONEY TO
FUND-RAISE, BUT THE REALITY IS
HE AND ALL OF HIS ENABLERS HAVE
BEEN ENGAGING IN EXTRAORDINARILY
VIOLENT RHETORIC, SORT OF
STOKING THE PASSIONS AND FLAMING
THE SORT OF SENSE THAT THE FBI
IS DOING THESE HORRIBLE THINGS.
WE HAD A GUNMAN WHO'S NOW DEAD
ATTACK THE FBI CINCINNATI FIELD
OFFICE.
WE'VE HAD OTHERS CHARGED WITH
MAKING THREATS AGAINST FBI
AGENTS.
ALL THESE THINGS HE'S DOING ARE
CREATING AN ENVIRONMENT OF
VIOLENCE.
IF HE GOES AND RELEASES
VIDEOTAPE OF THE SEARCH WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THOSE AGENTS AND
INVESTIGATORS TO BE IDENTIFIED,
I CAN'T THINK OF A MORE
IRRESPONSIBLE, DISGUSTING THING
FOR HIM TO DO ALL IN THE NAME OF
GENERATING POLITICAL SUPPORT,
ALL IN THE NAME OF SQUEEZING
ANOTHER $1.50 OUT OF THE
SUPPORTERS THAT HE HAS BEEN
BILKING NOW FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS.
>> THAT LEADS ME TO A QUICK
FOLLOW-UP, PETER, AND THAT IS,
WOULD THE FBI WANT TO SEE THAT
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE, IF HE'S
GOING TO RAISE THE SPECTOR OF
RELEASING THIS FOOTAGE, IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
TANTALIZING FOR THE FBI, FOR
INVESTIGATORS TO WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT TO SEE WHAT KIND OF
SECURITY MEASURES WERE BEING PUT
IN PLACE TO KEEP THOSE DOCUMENTS
SECURE.
WHO WAS COMING AND GOING.
THAT MIGHT BE USEFUL
INFORMATION.
>> WELL, SURE IT WOULD, AND I
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
BEEN REPORTED IS THAT AMONG THE
SUBPOENAS IF THERE ARE ONE OR
MORE THAT WERE ISSUED TO
MAR-A-LAGO AND TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS
INCLUDED CCTV OF THAT BASEMENT
ROOM.
SO THE QUESTION IS IF THIS IS
RELEASED, CERTAINLY AS AN
INVESTIGATORS PEOPLE WILL BE
LOOKING VERY CAREFULLY TO SAY,
OKAY, WHAT WERE THE VARIOUS
SITES WE COULD IDENTIFY THAT HAD
CCTV COVERAGE.
TWO, DID TRUMP AND HIS ATTORNEYS
ACTUALLY COMPLY WITH THE
SUBPOENA TO TURN OVER WHATEVER
FOOTAGE WAS REQUESTED, DEMANDED
IN THOSE SUBPOENAS, AND THREE,
IF THERE ARE THINGS IN THERE
THAT MIGHT BE RELEVANT TO THE
ONGOING INVESTIGATION, CERTAINLY
ANTICIPATE ANOTHER SUBPOENA OR
PERHAPS ANOTHER, YOU KNOW,
WARRANT TO COMPEL PRODUCTION OF
THAT FOOTAGE IF IT IS THE KIND
OF THING THAT MIGHT BEAR
RELEVANCE ON T